c'est pas des choses qu'on a l'habitude
de voir tous les jours c'est vraiment un
découpage complètement sa
cinématographie
un vrai régal pour ceux qui aiment la
bande dessinée
ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
pour cette dernière séance avant les
vacances parlementaires
cet après midi les sénateurs examinent
les conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire relative au projet de loi sur
la gendarmerie
il s'agit d'une petite révolution car
désormais les gendarmes passent sous
l'autorité du ministère de l'intérieur
ce rapprochement avec la police
nationale n'est pas une fusion a rappelé
brice hortefeux le ministre de
l'intérieur pour lui ce projet de loi
conforte le statut et l'identité
militaire de la gendarmerie tout de
suite donc direction l'hémicycle la
bonne après midi à tous sur public sénat
ma religion rappelle d'abord l'examen
des conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire chargée d'élaborer un texte
sur les dispositions restant en
discussion du projet de loi relatifs à
la gendarmerie nationale dans la
discussion générale la parole est un
monsieur jean faure rapporteur pour le
sénat de la commission mixte paritaire
vous avez la parole monsieur le
rapporteur
merci une seule président monsieur le
ministre et sa collègue
permettez moi d'abord monsieur le
ministre de vous féliciter pour votre
confirmation gouvernement bien sûr et
surtout pour votre nomination au poste
où vous êtes et nous souhaitons pleine
réussite dans vos nouvelles fonctions
avec la discussion des conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire qui s'est
tenue au sénat le 8 juillet dernier nous
avons aujourd'hui la dernière étape de
l'examen du projet de loi relatif à la
gendarmerie nationale en effet cela fait
presque un an que ce projet de loi a été
présenté par le gouvernement et déposés
en première lecture au sénat le projet
de loi présente un caractère historique
le rappel puisque la dernière loi portée
potentielle gendarmerie et remonte en
il constitue une réforme profonde
puisqu'ils organisent leur attachement
nageant dans mes nationale ministère de
l'intérieur conformément d'ailleurs à la
volonté du président de la république
à cet égard je voudrais rappeler
brièvement l'état d'esprit dans lequel
nous avons abordé au sénat
ce projet de loi les principales
modifications qui ont été apportées au
cours de la discussion parlementaire
avant même le dépôt du projet de loi la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées du sénat
présidée par notre collègue josselin de
rohan a constitué en son sein un groupe
de travail chargé de réfléchir à
l'avenir de l'organisation de la
gendarmerie
ce groupe de travail que je présidais
était composé de nos collègues michelle
demessine hubert haenel philippe
madrelle charles pasqua
yves pozzo di borgo et andré rouvière et
pendant quatre mois donc de décembre
2007 à mars 2008 notons de travail a
procédé à de très nombreuses auditions
et à plusieurs déplacements à l'issue de
nos travaux nous avons présenté 17
recommandations qui ont été adoptées à
l'unanimité de toutes les formations
politiques est reprise dans un rapport
d'information que nous avons publiée en
avril 2008 pour l'examen du projet de
loi bien entendu je me suis largement
fondée sur les recommandations de notre
commission
j'ai également entendu une quinzaine de
personnalités dans nos représentants du
ministère de l'intérieur bien sûr mais
également de la défense et de la justice
ainsi que des anciens directeurs
généraux de la gendarmerie
les officiers de gendarmerie des préfets
des magistrats je rappelle simplement je
l'avais déjà cité une fois mais je
trouve qu'elle est le marque bien la
prudence sénatoriales dans sa démarche
donc j'ai j'ai cherché à m'inspirer de
cette phrase qui date du décret du 20
mai 2009 103 dont le rapporteur avait
dit j'ai cherché à bien définir la part
d'actions que chaque département
ministériel peut exercer sur la
gendarmerie afin de sauvegarder cette
arme contre les exigences qui ne pouvait
trouver leur prétexte que dans
l'élasticité où l'obscurité de quelques
articles
donc c'est à partir de ces éléments
qu'avec notre collègue jean patrick
courtois rapporteur pour avis de la
commission des lois
nous avons présenté une vingtaine
d'amendements qui ont tous été adoptés
par nos commissions respectives tel
qu'adopté par le sénat en décembre
dernier le projet de loi qui comportait
au départ que dix articles en comporter
22 soit plus du double et les
principales modifications que nous y
avons donc introduit c'est d'abord
modifier l'intitulé de loi pour confère
une des manips dénomination plus
solennel
et mais plus important nous avons
entièrement réécrit l'article définition
l'émission la gendarmerie nationale afin
de mentionner expressément linke qui la
police judiciaire était un élément
essentiel d activité essentielle de la
gendarmerie d'affirmer son ancrage
territorial et souligné sa dimension
internationale notamment grâce à sa
participation aux opex
nous avons également introduit un nouvel
article pour consacrer le principe du
libre choix du service enquêteur par
l'autorité judiciaire
comme vous le savez la question des
relations avec les préfets suscité de
fortes inquiétudes au sein de la
gendarmerie
en définitive nous a encadré je me
dispositif de trois manières
d'une part nous ont précisé que
l'autorité des préfets ne s'exerce que
sur les commandants de gendarmerie
les groupements de gendarmerie afin de
préserver le principe hier afic
d'autre part nous avons affirmé que
cette autorité ne joue que pour la
sécurité publique et non pour les
missions judiciaires
et enfin nous avons mentionné qu'elle
s'exerce dans le respect du statut
militaire
c'est le son qu'on respecte bien la
colonne vertébrale que représente
l'autorité de la gendarmerie
au total je crois que nous sommes
parvenus un bon équilibre et je me
félicite que cet équilibre qui était
préservé par nos collègues députés
un autre sujet très délicat a concerné
la suppression de la procédure de
réquisition nous l'estimions que cette
procédure effectuée n'était pas
compatible avec le rattachement me sers
l'intérieur nous avons accepté de
supprimer cette réquisition mais nous
prévoyons toutefois de tempérament d'une
part maintenir une procédure
d'autorisation pour le recours à des
moyens exceptionnels
militaires tels que les véhicules
blindés par exemple pour les
hélicoptères mais d'autre part nous
avons souhaité encadrer l usage d armes
car surtout il en mafieux tank par les
gendarmes que par les policiers en
particulier afin de garantir la
traçabilité des ordres et pour terminer
nous avons adopté d'autres modifications
au texte du gouvernement afin de
notamment de reconnaître le rôle
essentiel joué par les réservistes de
gendarmes et national en tête finit-il
je crois pouvoir affirmer que au delà
des clivages politiques qui sont
légitimes et des points de vue qui ont
été exprimées sur l'opportunité ou non
de rattachement de renommée nationale
ministère l'intérieur
les travaux du sénat ont été marqués par
le souci de toutes les formations
politiques d'apporter toutes les
garanties pour que le maintien à l'ubu
alisme des forces de sécurité publique
et du caractère militaire notamment bris
auxquelles nous sommes ici très attaché
soit conservé je vais d'ailleurs salué
l'attitude constructive de nos collègues
de l'opposition avec le que nous avons
d'ailleurs adopté un certain nombre de
dispositions ou d'amendements ce projet
de loi il a été transmis en janvier à
l'assemblée nationale qu'il a adopté le
7 juillet dernier
de manière générale l'assemblée
nationale n'a pas apporté de
modifications majeures au texte qui a
été adopté par le sénat
la plupart des modifications apportées
par nos collègues députés sont d'orb
rédactionnelle et vise à conforter les
dispositions qui avait été approuvé par
le sénat
que ce soit pour le libre choix du
service enquêteurs de l'autorité
judiciaire ou sur d'autres points
toutefois deux principales différences
sont apparues entre les assemblées et
c'est sûr de ces deux points que je veux
revenir une seconde et qui ont porté
d'ailleurs sur la commission mixte
paritaire
la première concernait la définition des
missions de la gendarmerie qui y figure
à l'article 1
en effet on peut relever quatre
différents sens prend le texte adopté
par le sénat et celui qui avait été
adoptée par l'assemblée nationale
la phrase selon laquelle la police
judiciaire constitue
une mission essentielle gendarmerie et
qui avaient été ajoutées pensionnat
était à ce moment-là supprimée par
l'assemblée nationale à l'initiative de
sa commission des droits
ensuite la disposition d'après laquelle
la gendarmerie est compétente pour
assurer la sécurité publique et l'ordre
public particulièrement dans les zones
rurales avait précisé le sénat et péri
urbaines ainsi que sur les voies de
communication cette phrase a été enlevé
par nos collègues
là aussi sur la proposition de la
commission des lois en revanche la
commission de la défense de l'assemblée
nationale avait tenu à préciser que
l'agenda - contribuent à lutter contre
le terrorisme
ce qui nous a paru d'ailleurs par la
suite une très bonne idée et enfin à
l'initiative de philippe folliot député
l'assemblée nationale introduit une
disposition battre laquelle la
gendarmerie participe au contrôle et à
la sécurité
les armements nucléaires le compromis
auquel nous sommes arrivés si cet
article au sein de la commission
paritaire a consisté à reprendre
l'ensemble des ajouts des deux
assemblées
ainsi le texte que nous avons élaboré
mentionne la contribution de la
gendarmerie la lutte contre le
terrorisme et son rôle en matière de
désarmement nucléaire mais nous avons
également en commission mixte paritaire
rétabli les deux dispositifs que les
députés avaient souhaité supprimer ce
qui fait que finalement nous disposons
maintenant d'un texte qui nous paraît
parfaitement équilibré et il nous paraît
important pour nous sénateurs d'affirmer
l'ancrage territorial de la gendarmerie
auquel les élus locaux vous le savez
bien et la population des zones rurales
aussi sont très attachés et je vous le
rappelle monsieur le ministre
de même il nous paraît nécessaire
souligné le rôle important que joue la
gendarmerie en matière de police
judiciaire vous rappelle quand même que
ça représente 40 % de leur masse de
travail sur ce premier point le texte
élaboré avec méchante mixte paritaire
donne pleine satisfaction au sénat la
deuxième divergences avec l'assemblée
portait sur leurs réquisitions et l
usage des armes à feu tirant les
conséquences d'urgence du rattachement
de la gendarmerie au ministère de
l'intérieur
on a donc supprimé cette réquisition
mais compte tenu de l'importance de ces
questions qui touchent directement la
libertés publiques et les droits des
individus
nous avions je voulais dit tout à
l'heure encadrer la suppression de cette
procédure de réquisition en prévoyant
malgré tout une procédure d'autorisation
pour usage des moyens militaires et des
armes à feu avec un décret 6 et en
conseil d'état
les députés souhaitaient simplement un
décret simple là nous avions une
divergence est bien le texte élaboré par
la commission mixte paritaire
un s'inspire très largement du
dispositif qui avait été adopté par le
sénat
ainsi le recours aux moyens militaires
spécifiques dont dispose la gendarmerie
comme est blindé par exemple sera soumis
à une procédure d'autorisation définies
par décret en conseil d'état
en outre les conditions deux amants se
tend cas du maintien de l'ordre dans par
les gendarmes que les policiers
d'ailleurs sera également précisées par
décret en conseil d'état
nous tenons à ce déclin quand c'est
l'état parce que
l'avenir est inconnu ne savons pas
les décisions que sera appelé à prendre
devant on est des cas d'exception
1 mise à l'intérieur dans la
précipitation
donc nous avons un usage des armes dans
les gendarmes et parler les mobiles et
policiers lors de manifestations mieux
encadrer et on peut garantir une
traçabilité
en définitive je crois pour affirmer que
ce texte élaboré par la commission mixte
paritaire donne largement satisfaction
préoccupations que vous aviez exprimé
lors de la la lecture en science
publique et tout en prenant compte les
améliorations qui ont été apportées par
les députés et avec ce projet de noël en
a marre y verra son statut de forces
armées et ses missions consacré au
niveau législatif le rattachement mise
de l'intérieur permettra de renforcer la
coordination des deux forces de sécurité
en matière de lutte contre la
criminalité et donc d'améliorer la
sécurité des français
il permettra aussi de renforcer la
mutualisation des moyens entre la police
et la gendarmerie
en outre grâce à ce projet de loi les
militaires de la gendarmerie
bénéficeront d'une grille indiciaire
spécifique ce qui permettra d'aller vers
ce que tout le monde souhaitait c'est à
dire une parité globale de traitement de
carrière entre les gendarmes et les
policiers qui avaient été annoncés je le
rappel par le président de la république
enfin le caractère militaire national
sera préservé l'existence de deux forces
de sécurité l'une un statut civil
l'autre à statut militaire la
gendarmerie nationale constitue en effet
un atout majeur pour notre pays et la
sécurité des français
c'est d'ailleurs cette exigence qui a
guidé les travaux de la commission mixte
paritaire et qui nous a conduit à
élaborer un texte commun que nous vous
demandons chers collègues de bien
vouloir approuver
merci monsieur le rapporteur la parole
est maintenant à monsieur à la barre
l'ex secrétaire d'état à l'intérieur et
aux collectivités territoriales avait la
parole monsieur le ministre
ainsi monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
président de la commission de la défense
messieurs les les rapporteurs mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs le texte qui
vous est soumis aujourd'hui est
d'importance il constitue ni plus ni
moins la première réforme d'ampleur de
la gendarmerie nationale depuis quelques
200 en 1798 exactement comme l'a rappelé
excellemment votre rapporteur monsieur
jean faure que je remercie par ailleurs
pour ses félicitations
alors à l'heure où où se joue en quelque
sorte dans votre hémicycle l'histoire
autant que l'avenir de l'une de nos plus
vieille institution nationale
permettez moi tout d'abord de réagir sur
un fait présent si vous le permettez
comme vous le savez un attentat à la
voiture piégée a visé hier matin la
gendarmerie de vescovato en haute-corse
est devant vous représentants de la
nation je tiens bien entendu a condamné
avec fermeté cet acte terroriste
irresponsable qui aurait pu avoir des
conséquences dramatiques si heureusement
aucun blessé n'est à déplorer je
rappelle que l'explosion s'est produite
à proximité immédiate d'une caserne dans
laquelle vivent plusieurs familles de
gendarmes et alors même que des enfants
des jeunes enfants se trouvaient à
l'extérieur
je saisis cette occasion pour rendre
hommage aux militaires de la gendarmerie
nationale
et à l'ensemble des forces de sécurité
intérieure de corse
je sais le contexte souvent difficile
dans lequel ils exercent leur mission
périlleuse
je leur exprime le soutien du
gouvernement et la confiance du
gouvernement dans l'action qu'ils mènent
au service de la paix publique et du
respect du droit auquel aspire nous le
savons l'immense majorité des habitants
de corse
il en témoigne à chaque élection
le ministre de l'intérieur monsieur
brice hortefeux qui vous prie de bien
vouloir l'excuser
il est en déplacement à marseille pour
les tragique incendie que subit la
capitale de la région paca
il a demandé que tous les moyens soient
mis en oeuvre pour identifier pour
interpellé pour remettre à la justice
dans les meilleurs délais ceux qui ont
fait le choix de la violence dans l'île
le gouvernement réaffirme en outre la
détermination de l'état à faire
respecter la paix et la sécurité publics
en corse comme dans toutes les
collectivités locales de notre
territoire
c'est pour répondre à ce même objectif
de protection de nos concitoyens que le
précédent ministre de l'intérieur vous
avez présenté en
ob 2008 le projet de loi relatif à la
gendarmerie nationale je me réjouis
d'ailleurs de constater combien vous
voulez est approprié en quelque sorte
combien vous l'avez commenté combien
vous l'avez enrichi et je pense tout
particulièrement aux amendements de vos
deux rapporteurs monsieur jean faure et
jean patrick courtois
après plus de huit heures 8 heures de
débats intenses
nous arrivons à présent au point d'orgue
de la procédure législative
la commission mixte paritaire a adopté
la semaine dernière un texte équilibré
de quelque 27 articles contre 10
initialement texte qui rend compte
entièrement l'accord du gouvernement et
je voudrais en remercier bien entendu
tout particulièrement les présidents des
commissions de la défense et des lois
messieurs juste en rond et jean jacques
hyest ainsi que vos deux rapporteurs
alors si vous le permettez je voudrais
insister particulièrement sur trois
points qui me paraissent essentiels
premièrement je me réjouis de ce que le
texte adopté par la cmp confirme et
renforce les objectifs du projet de loi
vos débats ont montré combien nous
sommes unis au sein du gouvernement
comme sur l'ensemble comme sur
l'ensemble de ces bancs de votre
hémicycle par un même attachement à la
gendarmerie nationale cet attachement
vous l'avez exprimé par vos prises de
parole comme par vos abonnements à
gauche à droite comme au centre la
volonté de pérenniser une grande
institution qui assure avec efficacité
et proximité un service public de
sécurité a fait l'unanimité je ne prends
pas de le dire et je tiens elle
réaffirmé aucune fusion n'est à l'ordre
du jour l'objectif de cette loi est le
maintien de deux forces de sécurité
intérieure à statuts différents comme
l'a précisé le président de la
république en novembre 2007 lorsqu'il a
lancé ce travail d'intégration de la
gendarmerie nationale au ministère de la
intérieur et nous veillerons avec le
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur brice
hortefeux par conséquent à ce que ce
rapprochement soit mis en oeuvre dans le
respect de l'identité militaire des
gendarmes
nous seront également attentifs avec
brice hortefeux à ce qu'il se déroule
dans un souci d'efficacité le
rattachement organique de la gendarmerie
au ministère de l'intérieur doit ouvrir
de nouvelles perspectives d'amélioration
du service public
il doit favoriser les synergies les
complémentarités opérationnels et les
mutualisation des moyens notamment dans
la fonction soutien c'est sa raison
d'être en quelque sorte vous l'avez
compris la réforme qui vous est proposée
aujourd'hui n'est pas une réforme de
l'institution militaire c'est une
réforme nécessaire pragmatiques et
concrètes qui permettra d'améliorer
l'efficacité de notre politique de
sécurité et de conforter l'identité de
la gendarmerie nationale deuxième point
que je veux évoquer rapidement au delà
de cet accord fondamental
vous avez souhaité enrichir et vous
l'avez fait le projet de loi par un
travail parlementaire d'une grande
qualité
complétant le texte pourtant respectant
sa cohérence de base vous avez tenu à
confirmer la gendarmerie dans ses
différentes missions et en particulier
celle de défense et de police judiciaire
et parallèlement le gouvernement se
félicite que vous soyez parvenus dès la
première lecture un accord avec vos
collègues députés sur l'article 3
notamment relatifs aux prérogatives du
préfet le gouvernement approuve les
termes et le sens profond dans la
formulation que vous avez retenu il
équilibre parfaitement le rôle de
direction du préfet en matière de
sécurité publique et le respect de la
chaîne y est rare chic propre à la
gendarmerie en application de son statut
militaire
pour ce qui est
de l'exercice d'un mandat électoral par
un réserviste de la gendarmerie
nationale vous avez là encore trouvé un
excellent équilibre
puisque vous avez garantit ce droit tout
en protégeant les citoyens
en effet parce qu'elle entraîne la
qualité d'agent de police judiciaire dpj
l'activité de réservistes ne pourra
s'exercer dans la circonscription
d'élection aucun mélange des genres ne
sera donc possible de plus et c'est
important de nouvelles dispositions ont
été introduites concernant le transfert
au ministère de l'intérieur des
fonctionnaires et des agents non
titulaires des services de la
gendarmerie nationale ces aménagements
étaient nécessaires à l'adaptation de
l'organisation et du fonctionnement du
service public à la suite du
rattachement de la gendarmerie
cela se fera dans le respect des droits
des agents tels qu'ils sont inscrits
dans le texte
enfin je crois tout à fait pertinent que
le gouvernement remette un rapport
d'évaluation des premiers résultats du
rapprochement police gendarmerie dans
deux ans c'est à dire avec le recul
nécessaire plutôt que dès l'année
prochaine
la réalisation du rapport par une
instance extérieure au service de la
police et de la gendarmerie renforce
d'ailleurs cette dimension d'évaluation
cela n'empêchera pas de faire un point
sur les données chiffrées disponibles
chaque année lors de la préparation du
budget du ministère bien entendu
troisième et dernier point que je veux
évoquer devant vous je voudrais préciser
le sens de deux dispositions importantes
introduites lors de vos débats il s'agit
tout d'abord de la suppression de la
procédure de réquisition de la
gendarmerie pour l'exercice de missions
ordonnée par le ministère de l'intérieur
c'est la conséquence logique du
rattachement organique de la gendarme
note de la gendarmerie au ministère de
l'intérieur
celui ci n'a pas à requérir une force
dont il dispose déjà
cette évolution est naturellement
respectueuse des libertés
public ce projet de loi est l'occasion
de l'affirmer et vous avez insisté sur
ce point monsieur le rapporteur et
souscris complètement un décret en
conseil d'état fixera aussi les
conditions dans lesquelles il pourrait
être fait usage des armes à feu dans le
cadre du maintien de l'ordre par la
gendarmerie nationale comme par la
police nationale
mais je le rappelle fort heureusement
l'usagé des armes à feu est extrêmement
rare et doit le rester et il le restera
bien entendu comme prédécesseur au
ministère de l'intérieur en a pris
l'engagement devant vous le décret
garantira une traçabilité complète
complète des ordres donnés
cela se fera à droit constant c'est à
dire notamment dans le cadre de
l'application des dispositions du code
pénal
cela se fera sans recréer une procédure
aussi lourde que la réquisition explique
cela cela se fera et notamment par le
biais de dispositifs techniques
d'enregistrement des ordres de cette
façon à chaque ordre d'usagé d'une arme
à feu correspondre à une chaîne de
responsabilités clairement établie de
même pour l'utilisation de moyens
militaires spécifiques de la gendarmerie
dans le maintien de l'ordre
un décret en conseil d'état prévoir à un
dispositif d'autorisation expresse
l'engagement de ce type de moyens est et
restera très exceptionnel bien entendu
par nature liés à des situations de
désordre très grave
cette utilisation doit par delà
l'émotion légitime qu'elle peut susciter
chez nos concitoyens nécessité bien
entendu un encadrement très strict je
voudrais en second lieu vous rassurer
concernant l'implantation territoriale
de la gendarmerie à laquelle je sais que
vous êtes comme le gouvernement
extrêmement
tâchez le maintien du maillage
territorial est nécessaire pour assurer
la sécurité partout et pour tous je note
que la commission mixte paritaire a
retenu la phrase suivante et je la cite
entre guillemets la gendarmerie
nationale est destiné à assurer la
sécurité publique et l'ordre public
particulièrement dans les zones rurales
et périurbaines et les lieux rural que
je suis bien entendu est extrêmement
sensible à cette formulation
par ailleurs les règles en vigueur
concernant la compétence territoriale de
la police nationale ne sont pas remises
en cause les redéploiements entre la
police et la gendarmerie sont possibles
et permettent d'améliorer la cohérence
du dispositif global leur rapprochement
des deux forces permettra ainsi de
trouver les répartitions les plus
adaptées aux situations locales au cas
par cas
voilà monsieur le président messieurs
les présidents de commissions messieurs
les rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs le projet qui vous est
soumis qui est soumis à votre vote est
un texte équilibré
il s'agit d'une réforme de fond qui
s'inscrit dans le long terme et qui nous
donne les outils pour poursuivre
l'amélioration de la sécurité de nos
concitoyens
il ne s'agit pas d'une révolution mais
d'une évolution
cette évolution était nécessaire pour
adapter les moyens aux besoins de
l'époque sans mettre en cause les
spécificités qui font l'efficacité
ensemble des forces de sécurité
intérieure et notamment celle de la
gendarmerie
il nous appartient à présent de donner
tout son sens à cette réforme
en concrétisant sur le terrain ce
rapprochement entre la police nationale
et la gendarmerie nationale soyez en
certain avec brice hortefeux ministre de
l'intérieur nous veillerons à ce que
cette mise en oeuvre se fasse dans un
souci d'équilibré de complémentarité et
d'efficacité et ce afin de répondre aux
attentes de nos sécurités de sécurité
très légitime de l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
ministre je voulais vous dire monsieur
le ministre
senna tout entier s'associer à l'hommage
que vous avez rendu aux forces de
gendarmerie mais aussi à l'action des
services de gendarmerie de la sécurité
civile des sapeurs pompiers lors des
dramatiques incendies qui ravagent les
portes de marseille et que vous puissiez
leur transmettent l'hommage et la
gratitude du sénat bien dans la
discussion générale
la parole est à madame virginie klès
pour le groupe socialiste et apparentés
je remercie monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
renforcement du parlement textes
importants pour ne pas dire fondamentaux
ou même historique réflexion approfondie
concertation sereine respect des
institutions des élus nationaux comme
locaux des professionnels
bref tout ce que vous auriez voulu avoir
sur ces sessions parlementaires mais que
vous n'osez même plus demandés et encore
moins espéré était ce déjà ainsi avant
demain 2007
je n'en sais rien en tout cas pour ce
qui me concerne depuis octobre 2008 je
vis de l'intérieur sans vouloir faire de
jeu de mots plus ou moins à propos un
travail parlementaire échevelé des
structures et poursuivant des objectifs
politiques confuses sans cohérence fait
de précipitations d'examen bâclé par
manque de temps deux textes qui sont de
toute façon et dans le mépris le plus
absolu des parlementaires mises en
application avant même d'être débattue
quand ils ne font pas l'objet d'un ordre
venu d'en haut de vote conforme boulimie
législative qui ne riment décidément ni
avec simplification ni avec efficacité
du fait des modifications tous azimuts
introduit dans l'arsenal juridique
français boulimie qui finira par nous ou
et la symphonie pathétique sans chef
d'orchestre
je crains la cacophonie ainsi en est il
de cette loi prévoyant leur attachement
gendarmerie nationale au ministère de
l'intérieur loi qui a tout de même
échappé un fléau le vote conforme qui
n'a cependant pas échappé au
rétrécissement des délais ni à
l'abolition de la réflexion sereine et
approfondie grâce à la déclaration
d'urgence ni non plus à un calendrier
somme toute assez loufoques ou pour le
moins mal maîtrisé
pour rappel ce projet de loi a été
déposée le 23 juillet 2008 pour une
entrée en application le 1er janvier
débattue en décembre au sénat début
juillet à l'assemblée nationale après
réunion de la commission mixte paritaire
nous en voici donc nous envoie s'ils ont
comme dernier débat en séance publique
ce 23 juillet 2009
joyeux anniversaire passons sur ces
problèmes de forme pour en revenir au
fond quels sont les objectifs avoués ou
non du gouvernement
et quels sont ceux que nous pourrions
partager les moyens affichés sont ils de
nature à les atteindre réellement au
concours t-il à une autre femme
de fait le gouvernement tout à son
objectif idéologique de concentrer les
forces de sécurité sous silence à
l'autorité n'a j'espère en tout cas pas
bien mesuré les conséquences
institutionnelles juridiques politiques
et même économique de son texte
sinon il faudrait admettre qu'il ait
sciemment en danger les fondements mêmes
de notre république
dans sa présentation du projet madame
alliot marie alors ministre de
l'intérieur et après avoir effectué un
virage à 90 degrés en quittant le
ministère de la défense avait déclaré
que ce texte visait tout en garantissant
le maintien du statut militaire des
gendarmes a renforcé le dispositif de
sécurité intérieure je pense que madame
alliot marie était et toujours sans
doute attachés au maintien de ce statut
j'aimerais avoir la même certitude quant
à vos intentions monsieur le ministre
est assez lu ministre de l'intérieur
même si j'ai bien entendu vos
affirmations tout à l'heure j'ai du mal
à partager votre raisonnement est votre
optimisme sur l'absence de tout effet
néfaste de ce texte
oui cent fois oui il est nécessaire de
moderniser nos institutions
l'organisation et le fonctionnement des
forces de sécurité police
gendarmerie dans leur dualité actuelle
pour mieux assurer la protection des
français et apporter un service public
de qualité et proche des citoyens
mais fallait-il tout bousculer dans la
précipitation et malgré les affirmations
gouvernementales remettre
inéluctablement en cause le statut
militaire des gendarmes
la dualité des forces de police et de
sécurité la protection qu'apportait la
procédure de réquisition quant à
l'intervention des forces militaire sur
demande civile pour le maintien de
l'ordre intérieur et enfin la garantie
d'un maillage territorial efficace
jusque dans nos zones rurales
fallait il prendre le risque de voir les
missions confiées aux gendarmes n'être
plus que petit à petit celle que
n'assurerait pas la police nationale et
voir donc la gendarmerie nationale en
devenir le supplétif avant de
disparaître totalement
alors même que l'on parlait de quatrième
armes trop de personnes ont parlé deux
ou écrit sur la fusion de la gendarmerie
et de la police
aussi bien le ministre de la défense que
des parlementaires de la majorité que
les syndicats de police qui pour
certains l'appellent de leurs voeux
des gendarmes qui eux la redoute ses
répétitions ne sont pas le fait de
lapsus collectif sans fondement le
danger que nous dénonçons depuis des
mois est réel et imminent
oui le statut militaire et de fait
sérieusement mise à mal et c'est un avis
partagé semble-t-il par les auteurs d'un
rapport de l'inspecteur l'inspection
générale de l'administration
ce rapport aurait-il été classifiés
secret défense malgré ma demande
formulée auprès de madame la ministre de
l'intérieur le 23 avril dernier il ne
m'a toujours pas été possible en prendre
connaissance
quant au maintien du maillage
territorial avec une gendarmerie à
statut civil
nos amis belges peuvent témoigner des
dommages collatéraux inévitables
la mécanique est en marche coup d'envoi
suppression de la procédure de
réquisition le renforcement du rôle du
préfet place ainsi l'autorité militaire
sous la tutelle de l'autorité
administrative et rompt la chaîne
hiérarchique propre à la gendarmerie
interprétation interpénétration des
hiérarchies civils et militaires
parfaitement contraire à la tradition
républicaine
la réquisition est l'acte par lequel le
pouvoir civil confie une mission de
maintien ou de rétablissement de l'ordre
à une force militaire les gendarmes ne
serait donc pas d tout à fait militaire
modernisation seraient synonymes de
suppressions dans les dictionnaires
utilisé par le gouvernement
ou doit-on craindre la une nouvelle
doctrine d'utilisation de cette force
armée qu'elle traçabilité assurée quant
aux ordres donnés pour son emploi ainsi
désormais votre ministère devra faire
cohabiter sous le même toit et sous les
mêmes autorités environ cent mille
gendarmes 140 mille policiers avec la
mise en commun des moyens voire de
certaines formations avec le
rapprochement systématique des
conditions d'emploi et des missions et
déjà nés et grandis une inutile et
polémiques question au sein des forces
qui doivent oeuvrer dans un cadre
institutionnel serein et apaisé entre
devoir de réserve stricte et droit
syndical déroulement de carrière et
grille indiciaire logement de fonction
temps de travail effectif est astreint à
un devoir disponibilité permanente
répartition des territoires et des
missions les comparaisons se font déjà
cristallise des incompréhensions soulève
des interrogations fortes quant aux
différences est vécu comme des
disparités
les gendarmes sont encore des militaires
soumis aux contraintes militaire format
la culture militaire indissociables
dernières forêts séculaire avec le monde
rural qui permettent une utilisation
particulière souffle original est somme
toute économique des femmes et des
hommes qui ont choisi de servir sous ce
statut
la police a sa culture fonctionnement
les contraintes lui sont spécifiques
son action est tout aussi méritoire fait
d'autant de courage et de dévouement
c'est la présence de ces deux forces de
sécurité différentes et complémentaires
dans la france s'enorgueillit qui
garantit le bon fonctionnement de la
police au sens large
ce n'est malheureusement sans doute plus
pour très longtemps outre ces questions
et ses comparaisons d'un statut à
l'autre qu'elle simplification que la
gestion des ressources humaines en
interministériel pour les gendarmes
mesures disciplinaires laisser à la
défense mais gestion des carrières et
mise en disponibilité d'office à
l'intérieur comment imaginer que ce
dispositif perdurera sera efficace et
compréhensible par tous encore une
mauvaise raison de porter un autre coup
rapidement s'en prend le pari au statut
militaire des gendarmes qui seront donc
de plus en plus des as tout à fait
militaire alors le directeur général de
la gendarmerie nationale
général issu du corps pour combien de
temps la formation intégrale les
officiers sous-officiers de larmes
maintenir sans la défense pour combien
de temps sans oublier les missions
judiciaires loin d'être négligeable là
encore jusqu'à aujourd'hui l'autorité
judiciaire guern la possibilité de
choisir le service adéquat pour
effectuer les missions de police
judiciaire
et soyons logiques disparition du statut
militaire des gendarmes fusion la
gendarmerie nationale et de la police
nationale un seul coeur de politiciens
aussi lu alité perdu pour la police
judiciaire en résumé les gendarmes sont
des militaires qui ont des missions
relevant de la sécurité intérieure des
missions militaires et des missions
judiciaires et notamment de police
judiciaire ils dépendent est logiquement
me semblait-il du ministère de la
défense
les préfets exerçant sans s'immiscer
dans le service intérieur de larmes
l'autorité nécessaire au quotidien pour
des missions banal et avaient recours à
la procédure de réquisition en cas de
nécessité
une tutelle clairement militaire et la
mise à disposition des moyens auprès des
autorités civiles en tant que de besoin
une convention de mutualisation du 28
juillet 2008 entre les ministères de la
défense et de l'intérieur
engagé une meilleure synergie entre les
services une utilisation raisonnée et
rationnelle des moyens se laver sans
doute le tort d'être trop simple et
compréhensible par chacun sous couvert
d'économies de rationalisation de
simplification nous voici donc avec des
militaires pas tout à fait militaire
mais constituant la 4e armes
placée sous l'autorité civile mais
dépendant tout de même la gestion
disciplinaire de la défense leur
commandant d'unité territoriale sous
l'autorité des préfets
mais une direction générale son autorité
va général d'armée les effectifs verront
leur répartition territoriale effectué
par les préfets selon des consignes qui
laisse craindre que les zones
gendarmerie soient définies à terme par
défaut uniquement sans oublier les
missions judiciaires sous une troisième
autorités civiles vous gommez des
frontières légales historique
républicaine entre nos deux forces de
sécurité vous parachuté au sein des
ministères civils dans un fonctionnement
civils des militaires au fonctionnement
militaire sans vous préoccuper des
difficultés tant humaines
qu'organisationnel que vous créez ni de
la réelle qualité du service public qui
en ressortira une véritable réforme
aurait nécessité en tout premier lieu
d'analyser les spécificités et les
complémentarités de nos forces de
sécurité
mais le souhait du gouvernement était
sans doute différent et voulait
constituer le plus vite possible une
force unique de sécurité civile ce
pouvait être un objectif politique
ils devaient être présentés et débattus
comme tel monsieur le ministre aux
questions faut-il favoriser les
synergies entre la police et la
gendarmerie nationale
faut-il conforter l'existence de deux
forces de sécurité l'une de statut civil
l'autre de statut militaire dualité qui
répondent aux besoins de notre politique
de défense et de sécurité
faut-il préserver le maillage
territorial du service public de la
sécurité services dont monsieur le
premier ministre lui-même affirme qui
doit être un service de proximité
attentif aux sollicitations de nos
concitoyens je vous réponds avec force
et conviction
au nom du groupe que je représente ici
oui oui et oui je le dis et la firme
avec d'autant plus de conviction que
bien que la droite s'affirme seul
légitime pour traiter des questions de
sécurité
les résultats en la matière ne sont pas
à la hauteur des effets d'annoncé
tonitruante et coups de menton
volontaire ponctuée d'une inflation
législative répressives en grande partie
soumise à l'exploitation médiatique et
compassionnelle de faits divers depuis
votre retour au pouvoir
oui monsieur ministre la gauche est
attachée à la sécurité
nous estimons que la sécurité des
français et l'organisation des services
qui concourent à l'assuré tant civils
que militaires méritent plus et mieux
que ce que vous lui offrez en deux mots
sérieux et responsabilité
le texte qui nous est soumis aujourd'hui
reste malgré les corrections font
serment inacceptable il ne permettra en
rien amélioré la sécurité conduira
inéluctablement à la disparition du
statut militaire des gendarmes à la
fusion des fores de sécurité en accord
unique de statut civil organisation de
sinistre mémoire à trois reprises déjà
dans l'histoire française et enfin à la
désertification à la matière de nos
zones rurales
je suis persuadé que nombre de mes
collègues partagent cette analyse
y compris sur les bancs de la majorité
et quand bien même certaines combien
même une certaine discipline ou adorent
voir de raison
strictes nous peut-être qu'ils étaient
militaires les empêcherait de l'affirmer
monsieur le ministre
le groupe que je représente est trop
attachée aux valeurs républicaines pour
accepter le texte que vous nous
soumettez nous voterons donc contre
merci ma chère collègue
la parole est maintenant madame eliana
ceci pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen sénateurs du parti
de gauche
la parole mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président monsieur
léninisme chers collègues
les conclusions de cette commission
mixte paritaire sur le projet de loi
relatif à la gendarmerie nationale ne
peuvent que renforcer les forces les
fortes critiques que notre groupe avait
émis lors de sa discussion devant notre
assemblée
cela dit auparavant je voudrais
protester contre cette détestable
pratique gouvernementale qui consiste à
faire débattre le parlement de textes
entrer dans les faits avant même d'avoir
été votée en effet malgré l'urgence
d'ailleurs compté stade déclarée sur ce
texte en août 2008 le sénat l'a examiné
en 200 ans en décembre 2008 l'assemblée
nationale le 7 juillet 2009 et nous le
votons aujourd'hui depuis 1er janvier de
cette année la gendarmerie nationale est
donc placée sous la pleine autorité du
ministère de l'intérieur
la gendarmerie radon qu rejoint la
police sous les ors d'une même autorité
ministérielle pour la quatrième fois de
son histoire les précédentes étant les
premier et second empire et le régime de
vichy
je ne voudrais pas faire ici amalgames
déplacés
entre ces périodes historiques et la
nôtre bien évidemment mais je trouve
tout de même que ce nouveau rattachement
est révélateur d'un certain état
d'esprit
c'est d'ailleurs sans doute ce qui a
motivé l'opposition de tous ceux qui
voient potentiellement se profiler
derrière ce texte à recul des libertés
publiques et des droits individuels
pour appliquer sans entrave la politique
sécuritaire centralisatrice t pour tout
lire autoritaire du président de la
république nous nous étions donc opposé
à ce projet de loi qui organise le
rattachement organique opérationnel et
budgétaire de la gendarmerie au
ministère de l'intérieur pour deux
raisons principales qui recèle des
dangers pour notre démocratie
la première c'est la concentration en
une seule main de tous les pouvoirs et
de tous les moyens affectés à la
sécurité intérieure à cet égard la loi
de programmation militaire couplé avec
cette loi sur la gendarmerie nationale
organise en effet la toute puissance du
ministère de l'intérieur sur celui de la
défense
la seconde c'est la probable mise en
cause à terme de cette spécificité
républicaines et démocratiques de notre
pays
quelle existence de deux forces de
polices différentes
il ne faudrait voir nous dit on dans ce
projet de loi que la suite logique d'un
processus engagé depuis plusieurs années
une clarification et la simple
adaptation du droit à la pratique en
vigueur depuis six ans nous pensons
pourtant que s'il s'agissait uniquement
de moderniser de mutualiser des moyens
d'améliorer les conditions d'emploi de
ces deux forces et d'assurer une
meilleure coopération entre elles le
rattachement au ministère de l'intérieur
ne s'imposait pas afin de respecter en
apparence le dualisme républicain de
deux forces de police ce texte ne remet
pas directement en cause le statut
militaire de la gendarmerie
mais ils vident subrepticement de salle
ovide subrepticement de sa raison d'être
tout d'abord en supprimant la procédure
de la réquisition pour l'engagement des
unités de gendarmerie mobile en matière
de maintien de l'ordre
exclure ainsi la gendarmerie du champ
d'application du dispositif de la
réquisition pour la participation au
maintien de l'ordre c'est clairement lui
dénier l'une des spécificités des forces
militaires aussi est-il spécifié
spécieux de justifier cet abandon comme
la conséquence logique du rattachement à
l'intérieur au motif que la réquisition
permettrait à l'autorité civile
d'obtenir la mise en oeuvre de moyens
vont elles ne disposent pas cette
procédure n'est pas une entrave à
l'efficacité
elle est avant tout le signe de la
subordination et de l'obéissance des
armes et aux autorités civiles
elle est aussi une garantie écrite pour
les commandants d'unités contre
d'éventuels excès de pouvoir l'emploi de
la gendarmerie dans des opérations de
maintien de l'ordre sans réquisition
écrite même s'il est évident que cette
procédure a besoin d'être modernisée et
donc une grave atteinte aux principes
républicains
sur ce point d'ailleurs le texte de la
commission mixte paritaire est en recul
par rapport à ce que le sénat avait
adopté puisque l'utilisation de certains
moyens militaires étaient strictement
encadré le décret en conseil d'état pour
usage de véhicules blindés appareils par
exemple été remplacé par un décret aux
simples et la traçabilité des ordres
pour l'emploi de la force ne relèvera
que d'une circulaire ministérielle le
placement direct des commandants
d'unités sous l'autorité des préfets est
une autre manière de contourner le
statut de cette force en mettant en
cause le principe d'obéissance
hiérarchique inscrits dans le statut
général des militaires
la perte de substance progressive du
statut militaire des gendarmes avec
leurs obligations inhérentes de
disponibilité permanente et de
casernement aura fatalement des
conséquences négatives sur la sécurité
en milieu rural l'une des vocations
quand même de la gendarmerie
la nuit risque malheureusement de
montrer peu à peu que nous ne pourront
plus disposer d'une force toujours
disponible au moindre coût et dont les
effectifs diminueront au total monsieur
le ministre votre projet de loi loin de
clarifier une situation et permettre une
plus grande efficacité une meilleure
coopération entre nos forces de sécurité
va soulever plus de problèmes qu'il n'en
résoudra méo naudin
nous refusons la banalisation de
l'emploi de la force armée au quotidien
car elle contrevient à l'équilibré
public un des pouvoirs et sert de
prétexte à la mise en oeuvre d'une
politique du tout sécuritaire
c'est donc pour cet ensemble de raisons
que le groupe crc spg maintiendra son
vote contre ce projet de loi
ma chère collègue dans la suite de la
discussion générale la parole est un
monsieur françois fortassin pour le
groupe rassemblement démocratique social
et européen
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
tu as eu françois
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues depuis
longtemps la traduction française en
matière de forces de sécurité s'appuie
sur une dualité sidi les militaires et
cette dualité est sans doute à l'origine
de ce socle républicain auquel nous
sommes particulièrement attachés
surtout en matière de sécurité
intérieure
l'essentiel au fonds étant de protéger
le droit des citoyennes et on peut
s'apercevoir qu'il faut qu'il y ait
sinon une séparation totale mais un état
d'esprit différent et dans l'histoire
récente
on peut évoquer l'action qu'a mené la
gendarmerie lors des événements de 1968
alors que les forces civiles étaient
particulièrement défaillante bloqué si
longue absence
ce que nous craignons c'est que avec ce
projet de loi c'est que ce qui fait le
pivot est le pilier de la stabilité
républicaine soit légèrement altérée
être gendarme ça n'est pas qu'une
question de statut c'est un état
d'esprit et nous devrons d'autant plus
veiller à conserver cet état d'esprit et
à mettre des garde-fous pour qu'il
perdure ont d'autant plus que le
recrutement n'est base de recrutement
ont considérablement évolué
ce que nous créions aussi c'est que le
lien historique avec la défense
risque d'être rompu certes vous avez
donné monsieur le ministre un certain
nombre de garanties mais est-ce qu'au
fil du temps il n'y aura pas une
véritable fusion et cela est assez sinon
dangereux du moins inquiétant en termes
d'aménagement du territoire
car dans les zones rurales en
particulier la gendarmerie assure plus
qu'une question de sécurité ce qui est
la caractéristique de la marne c'est
qu'elle est fortement ancrée à l'esprit
républicain et c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles il y a
en outre les maires ruraux et les élus
ruraux
quelle que soit leur sensibilité un lien
extrêmement étroits je peux dire que
dans les zones rurales que je connais
bien comme vous monsieur le ministre
les gendarmes font partie du paysage et
ils font d'autant plus partie du paysage
ils doivent se fondre le plus totalement
dans la population et cela il nous faut
le maintenir
alors qu' un certain nombre d'évolutions
techniques et technologiques
on aurait tendance à les faire s'écarter
de cette mission qui est absolument
indispensable
je crois que on ne peut pas nier non
plus c'est la force du renseignement
qu'avait l'agent de la gendarmerie et
qui est en train un tout petit peu de
s'étioler
dès l'instant où la culture ne sera pas
tout à fait la même
voilà ce que je souhaitais dire et puis
il ya aussi d'autres éléments
il faut certes qui travaillent
conjointement mais on à travers quelques
exemples
je n'en citerai qu'un c'est l'épisode de
dramatique de la mort du préfet erignac
où on a pu voir que entre police et
gendarmerie
il n'y a pas eu forcément une relation
de coopération extrêmement étroite alors
cela doit être incontestablement
améliorée c'est une bonne chose aussi
que la gendarmerie soit amené à lutter
contre le terrorisme mais dans les
espaces ruraux les autres formes de
criminalité sont beaucoup plus
importantes que le terrorisme et il ne
faudrait pas que en voulant lutter
efficacement contre le terrorisme
on en oublie les missions historiques
qui sont celles de gendarmerie depuis
les dizaines d'hommes dans cet esprit
cet esprit républicaines nous devons le
conserver vous avez monsieur le ministre
et les assembler soi le sénat ou à
l'assemblée nationale au travers d'un
certain nombre d'amendements essayer
d'améliorer les choses
mais il ya encore du pain sur la planche
et puis au fond ce qui n'a pas été très
bien compris chez un certain nombre
d'élus c'est la question que l'on se
pose est-ce qu'il était nécessaire de
changer en quelque sorte le statut et
pourquoi ce rattachement au ministère de
l'intérieur
là dessus des réponses nous ont pas
totalement satisfait et c'est la raison
pour laquelle la grande majorité de
notre groupe ne saurait donner un aval à
un cadre normatif qui à défaut organisé
lui en libre entre les deux forces
une donne l'impression d'un mariage
forcé c'est du moins le sentiment qu qui
est celui des gendarmes que je peu
fréquentées damman département merci aux
enchères que l'oeil la parole est
maintenant à monsieur jacques gauthier
pour le groupe e l'union pour un
mouvement populaire
la parole mon cher collègue seul
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
c'est notre collègue et berne elle qui
aurait dû intervenir au lent du groupe
ump
mais il a été retenu en dernière minute
à l'extérieur et vous prie de l'excuser
alors comme les ministres et comme le
rapporteur je voudrais rappeler
l'importance de ce projet de loi et sa
dimension historique puisque cela a été
dit la précédente réorganisation est
l'émission la jardinerie défini remonter
à la loi du 28 germinal de l'ancise je
traduis 1798 dans la logique des
évolutions intervenues depuis 2002 ce
texte place la gendarmerie nationale
sous l'autorité du ministre et de
l'intérieur et tire naturellement des
conclusions de ce rapprochement
le modèle français de dualité des forces
de sécurité intérieure n'est pas remis
en cause n'est pas remis en cause le
statut militaire de la gendarmerie est
préservé et réaffirmé le statut
militaire de la gendarmerie est préservé
et réaffirmé bis repetita toutes les
garanties de la pérennité de ces forces
sont réunis et vous savez monsieur
ministres que tous ici
nous y sommes très attachés je voudrais
également insisté sur les conditions et
les conséquences du rattachement de la
gendarmerie au ministère de l'intérieur
deux points ne semble essentiel à cet
égard le rôle du préfet il a été évoqué
la réquisition usage d'armes à feu ou de
moyens militaires spécifiques qu'ils
étaient des inquiétudes pour certains de
nos collègues le texte précise le rôle
du préfet comme hugo souhaitions ce
notorité ne remet pas en cause le
principe hiérarchique le préfet n'exerce
pas le commandement des unités
cette fonction relève naturellement des
responsables de cette dernière dans le
respect de la chaîne hiérarchique
l'intervention du préfet ne remet donc
pas en cause la cohérence du dispositif
territorial
en ce qui concerne la réquisition son
principe pour l'emploi de la gendarmerie
au maintien de l'ordre et moderniser la
solution dégagée par la commission mixte
paritaire nous convient parfaitement
elle prévoit d'une part une procédure
d'autorisation dans les conditions
définies par un décret en conseil d'état
et le rapporteur a bien insisté sur ce
point et d'autres pas renvoie à un
décret en conseil d'état pour les
conditions d'usagé des armes à feu pour
le maintien de l'ordre
nous souhaitions en plein accord avec
notre rapporteur de la commission
enfants préserver la nécessaire
référence à un décret en conseil d'état
concernant un domaine qui touche
directement aux libertés publiques et
aux droits des individus
par ailleurs il faut maintenir et cela a
été évoqué une traçabilité des ordres
afin de permettre la vérification de la
légalité de l'ordre d'agir
j'en viens à présent aux missions la
gendarmerie le projet de loi les
consacre et permet d enrichir ses
missions seront désormais précisé dans
un seul texte je les rappelle exécution
des lois missions judiciaires dont au
premier chef la police judiciaire j
insiste la sécurité et l'ordre public
le renseignement et l'information des
autorités publiques
la mission de défense la lutte contre le
terrorisme et la sécurité des armements
nucléaires
l'action internationale notamment dans
le cas des opérations extérieures gas
grâce au travail de notre excellent
rapporteur nous avons apporté deux
modifications qui reste dans le texte
final le rôle très important que la
gendarmerie nationale joue dans le
domaine de la police judiciaire et sa
nécessaire présence territoriale
sur ce dernier point il est très
important aux yeux de bien préciser dans
la loi que la gendarmerie est compétente
pour assurer la sécurité publique et
l'ordre public particulièrement dans les
zones rurales et périurbaines ainsi que
sur les voies de communication c'est un
apport majeur de la haute assemblée que
je tenais à relever parce qu ils
soulignent l'importance de l'ancrage
territorial de la gendarmerie nationale
en particulier dans les zones rurales
grâce au maillage territorial assurée
par ces brigades que nous apprécions
tous
je me réjouis également que la cmp soit
arrivé à un accord sur le régime
électoral des réservistes est entré
favorable à l'idée d'encourager
l'engagement à servir dans la réserve
qui participent à ce lien fort entre les
armées et la nation et qui permet de
mieux faire connaître les forces armées
au sein de la population et chez les
élus dernier point sur lequel je
souhaitais insisté l'obligation qui est
faite au gouvernement mais fais ministre
de rendre compte tous les deux ans dans
un rapport d'évaluation remis au
parlement des conséquences concrètes du
texte cet outil nous le devons à
l'initiative d'un trait excellent
collègue jean pierre leleux nous
permettra d'exercer notre vigilance je
peux vous en assurez monsieur le
ministre
afin d'évaluer les modalités du
rattachement organique et budgétaire de
la gendarmerie au ministère de
l'intérieur
l'état doit veiller à ce que gendarmes
et policiers soient traités de manière
équitable est globalement équilibré
il faut éviter que ne se développent des
surenchères dont les effets pervers sont
déjà bien connus notre conviction est
que l'existence de deux forces
différentes mines civil l'autre
militaire et le partage des rôles entre
la gendarmerie et la police nationales
sont non seulement
dition de notre république mais
répondent également aux exigences de
protection des libertés publiques
ces deux forces doivent donc être
maintenue pour toutes ces raisons
monsieur le ministre
le groupe ump du sénat votera sans
réserve les conclusions de la cmp
ce vote est l'occasion pour nous de
réaffirmer notre attachement à la
gendarmerie nationale et notre
reconnaissance à tous les gendarmes pour
le travail accompli
jour et nuit sur le terrain il était
également l'occasion pour notre groupe
de réaffirmer fortement notre volonté de
garder un jardin national son statut
militaire
ce texte est important parce que la
gendarmerie est dans notre pays une
institution majeure à laquelle les
français sont particulièrement attachés
n'oublions pas la mission que les
français nous ont confié assurer la
sécurité de tous et partout sur le
territoire de la république
avec ce texte pragmatique est nécessaire
monsieur le ministre nous allons
améliorer l'efficacité notre politique
de sécurité et conforter l'identité de
la gendarmerie nationale je vous
remercie
merci mon cher collègue
je rappelle qu'en application de
l'alinéa 42 années de l'article 42
alinéa 12 du règlement
aucun amendement n'est recevable sauf
accord du gouvernement sur les articles
1 à 11
je ne suis saisi d'aucun amendements y
at il eu demande de parole sur l'un des
quelconque de ses articles
le vote est donc réservée conformément à
l'article 42 de notre règlement son
alinéa 2 je vais mettre aux voix
l'ensemble du projet de loi dans la
rédaction qui résulte du texte proposé
par la commission mixte paritaire
demandes d'explications de vote
oui voilà vous voulez une amie marie
payet voilà ta ligue où les vous avez la
parole ma chère collègue
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je
reconnais très volontiers le travail
important accompli par le sénat et par
notre rapporteur jean faure dont on ne
dira jamais sait ici combien on est
content de le voir au banc d'essai de
cette assemblée dans des conditions
agréables et satisfaisante pour tout le
monde
j'ai voté contre ce texte en commission
je voterai donc contre ce texte en
séance aujourd'hui comme j'ai voté
contre l'article 55 de la loi de
programmation militaire c'est un vote
personnel qui n'engage pas évidemment le
groupe auquel j'appartiens à la manne
marie payet
''j'avais la parole mes chers collègues
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voterai
les conclusions de la cmp
mais j'aimerais que le gouvernement se
penche sur les situations des gendarmes
ultramarins qui subissent une véritable
discrimination quand contrairement à
leurs collègues et leurs collègues
métropolitains
ils ne peuvent choisir d'effectuer leur
carrière dans leur région d'origine
je vous interrogez le 8 janvier dernier
monsieur le ministre
par le biais d'une question orale ma vie
alors rassurée en me disant que l'entrée
en vigueur du décret portant statut
particulier du corps des sous-officiers
de gendarmerie allait donner
satisfaction aux gendarmes de
l'outre-mer
mais l'arrêté d'application qui était en
cours d'élaboration en janvier n'a pas
encore été publiée j'aimerais savoir
s'il valait très bientôt monsieur le
ministre
quand je reçois tous les jours de
nombreux courriers de gendarmes qui
l'attendent avec impatience je remercie
merci marche
chers collègues pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote je vais donc vous
mettre aux voix l'ensemble du projet de
loi dans la rédaction qui résulte du
texte proposé par la commission mixte
paritaire
ceux qui sont favorables à son adoption
de manifestants dans l'âme un avis
contraire il est adopté
vous venez de suivre la lecture des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire relative au projet de loi sur
la gendarmerie